- On s'attendait à une victoire
facile. Les Ontariens ont
finalement assisté à un
raz-de-marée conservateur.
- 21 h 18 Radio-Canada prévoit
si la tendance du vote
se maintient...
- L'affaire aura été rapide :
moins de 20 minutes après la
fermeture des bureaux de vote,
Doug Ford était déjà donné
victorieux et majoritaire.
Une victoire sismique
qui n'a pas laissé grand place
aux partis d'opposition.
Le NPD est arrivé deuxième
avec 9 sièges de moins qu'au
déclenchement des élections.
Dans son fief de Hamilton,
Andrea Horwath s'est adressée
à ses militants.
Émue, elle a offert sa démission
après 13 ans à du NPD.
Les libéraux non plus n'ont pas
réussi leur pari avec seulement
un siège de plus qu'en 2018.
Une défaite cuisante,
qui ne leur confère même pas
le statut de parti officiel.
Leur chef Steven Del Duca
a aussi démissionné
après avoir été défait dans
sa propre circonscription.
- Une élection qui risque
de profondément changer le
paysage politique ontarien.
Pourtant, ces résultats
reflètent la volonté
d'une minorité de citoyens.
Car le taux de participation
était anémique : 4ent,
un creux historique.
Un message visiblement reçu
par Doug Ford. Au lendemain de
l'élection, le premier ministre
adopte un ton rassembleur.
Avec une super majorité
de 83 sièges sur 124
et deux partis d'opposition
en pleine reconstruction,
les conservateurs devraient
avoir les coudées franches p
les quatre prochaines années.
Mais avec un taux de
participation aussi faible,
Doug Ford sait qu'il devra
adapter son style ance
s'il veut prouver qu'il est
le premier ministre
de tous les Ontariens.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Conto.onto.onto.onto.ont.